hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast oxidative stress and
schizophrenia a translational approach I
am Judy oror of labits and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we have a
few important announcements before we
begin this presentation has been
approved for a category 1 continuing
medical education credit by Loma Linda
University if you are interested in
obtaining CMEs after attending this
presentation please click on the get
your free c c credits button in the
bottom left corner of the event screen
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through a green Q&A button lower
left I would now like to introduce
today's speaker Professor Kim Kang do
Professor Kim do is director of the
center for psychiatric neuroscience at
the University Hospital of loan
Switzerland her current major interest
lies in bridging basic Neuroscience with
problems clinical
Psychiatry since 1999 she set up a
translational research program aimed at
a better understanding of the causes and
mechanisms leading to schizophrenia
phenotypes in order to develop markers
for early diagnosis new drug targets as
well as preventive and therapeutic
measures building on an Innovative
hypothesis she demonstrated that
oxidative stress induced among others by
glutathione gsh deficit may represent a
hub on which both genetic and
environmental risk factors converge
during neurod development leading to the
impairment of neural connectivity and
synchronization and to cognitive
deficits as observed in patients in
addition to her research activities
Professor Kimo also works on
professional education and public
Outreach towards better care and cure of
major psychiatric disorders I will now
turn it over to Professor doe for her
presentation
hi
everybody um today I want to begin with
a story with a young adolescent 14 years
old with school Problems P Behavior with
16 16 years old drug abuse begin to hear
voices 18 years old the first
psychiatric
hospitalization and from there on 18 to
21 many crazes of Emer emergency
hospitalization and failure of
professional
formation this is a typical story for a
young adult affected by
schizophrenia which is a brain major
psychiatric disorders affecting one to
3% of the world population it we also
include all psychotic disorders it is a
neural disorder with a complex
interaction between genetic and
environmental risk factors with a
progressive Evolution and psychosis
generally start during adolescence and
young adult to which is a critical phase
of psychosocial
development and um schizophrenia
presents a quite heterogenous clinical
picture and the symptoms are
classically uh uh divided in positive
symptoms and negative symptoms and which
are based diagnostic positive uh such as
hallucination delusion the negative
symptoms which more characterized by
Retreat of personalities affecting
language affects will pleasure and
social domains but maybe the most
invalidating symptoms are the cognitive
deficit which affect all executive
function and not talking about the basic
symptoms which are the maybe the most
specific one to for
schizophrenia affecting perception motor
and self
disorders so this apply well for chronic
phases but not all to the early
phases psychotic disorders also is known
to evolve through various stages so the
first psychotic episode is known to be
preceded by a prodromal phase with subal
symptoms and treatment delay has
negative impact on the outcome
increasing the relapse rate an early
detection and early intervention has
become a major Focus for research and
service
development and Philip Kus in our
psychiatric dep department has uh
designed a clinical strategy to the
improve this outcome in order to reduce
the delay to Diagnostic and and also
development of stage specific treatment
and for that we need valid biomar for
good definition of stage for early
intervention and also we need uh for
mechanism to understand mechanism for
having stage specific treatment
targets so for that uh we have since
some years now develop a translational
approach in which we have in parallel
both the clinical uh Branch so working
with patients and the pric pr clinical
Branch working with animal models and
trying to have the same assessment end
points in the two brand from
genetic um biochemical morphology
neurophysiology Psychopathology or
behavior or social functioning in the
two one and having a tight interaction
between the two uh clinical and pical
branch in order to develop biomar which
may be useful for early identification
of patient definition of various
stages uh assessment of illness
progression and uh monitoring of
treatment efficacy and also understand
mechanism for uh new treatment and even
maybe treatment a preventive
taret so the cartoon now from Thomas
Insel highlights the main anomalies
found in chronic
schizophrenia mainly the diffusion
marination and the reduced so excitatory
inhibitory
imbalance um and today's talk will
mainly focus on the reduced internal Ron
activity and the question still remain
open for the earlier phase whether they
these impairment could be used as early
biomarkers which are needed to enhance
prediction accuracy of clinical measures
and to develop early intervention
strategies now today's talk I would like
with you to ask three question could
Redux disregulation be responsible for
some schizophrenia pheno tyes including
fast piking pvab me internal RS and mine
impairments could glutamate nmba
receptor impairment inflammation and
dopamine overload interacting with
oxidative stress be considered as a core
mechanism and could antioxidant Redux
modulators protect against oxidative
stress and contribute to the prevention
of the
disease let's now first look at the
pathopysiology of schizophrenia based on
our own work and also from work of many
labs we propose that Redux disregulation
in full interaction with nmba receptor
hyperfunction and inflammation represent
one Hub on which converge various causal
genetic and environmental risk factors
during the neuro development and leading
to structural and functional
connectivity empowerment which then
could be at the basis of the symptoms
and dimension in terms of risk fact
genetic risk factors uh so many
genomewise studies uh containing up to
300 patients highlighted for example the
dopamine related system genes and you
may have heard the newest aspect of the
role of dopamine in the disease with the
webinar of Professor Antony Grace also
the glutamate related
genes are the nmda receptor function and
oxidative stressfree genes other the
antioxidant uh system related genes as
well as the immune system related genes
so highlighted in R are genes which has
been known to be directly involved or
generating oxidative
stress and now in term of environmental
risk factors many known risk factors
affecting the Fatal atal or childhood
period such as inflammation
hypoxia uh Pia or insults in adults have
been shown to induce oxidative stress
and this is the conversion of these two
risk factors may lead now that we will
see how to redu this regulation and we
will see how redu dis regulation
oxidative stress may lead to micro
circuit affecting VAB meuron and mcro
affecting
marination so our first spring cap
observation was the obser is the
decrease of ctin levels in cereal spinal
F of drug naive patient and later on
confirmed by magnetic resonance
spectroscopy in prefontal CeX of
schizophrenia patients and searching for
the code we have seen that the two
synthetizing enzyme time of cion so the
main endogenous cellular Redux regulator
and antioxidant so the this genes are
associated with the disease and most
importantly we have seen that the
highest genotype at um uh concerning uh
polymorphism of the key synthetizing
enzyme of cut the
gclc so the highrisk genotype has
functional
consequences as you can see here in
fatro Blast of schizophrenia chronic
schizophrenia patient the highrisk GCL
genotypes when challenged with oxidative
stress uh has lower cut time content and
also lower synthetizing enzyme activity
and protein act uh expression and
recently leing scene thanks to Magnetic
uh resonance
specop so mrss have shown now in early
psychosis patient that the highis
genotype patient also has lower catar
levels as compared to the low risk
genotype so the at least so gclc so the
glutathion uh high res genotype can
predict low brain prote levels so now at
least in early psychosis patient the
patan levels decrease may depend on the
percentage of high risk patient in the
samples we are not the only lab who have
seen oxidative stress in schizophrenia
many Studies have shown abnormal
antioxidant levels and sign of oxidative
stress both in per peripheral tissue and
nervous tissue of schizophrenia patient
and including also copy number variation
and risk Gene which are directly related
to antioxidant
system so the Redux balance which is the
balance between antioxidant and reactive
and oxygen and nitrogen species is quite
critical in the brain as the brain
compared to other organ has a very high
oxidative
metabolism so when the
unbalance is quite severe oxidative
damage on proteins lipids DNA can occur
and have drastic IR irr irreversible
effects but if there is only a slight
imbalance so that kind of what we call
Redux dis regulation there can be
reversible oxidation of TI residues and
proteins that can have change
modulations of of the function and can
have impact on neurotransmission
proliferation
differentiation uh of cells specifically
in the early in the development and I
want also to mention Redux control is
more General than oxidative stress
indeed it is hypothetized by D tones
that
besides uh invol being involved in
direct signaling such as the redox
signaling pathway here antioxidant
system such as tho redoxin
or can exert a modulation on other uh
signaling system such as the ionic
signaling system that we will see today
an example concerning nmda receptors or
the kise system and they can thus exert
octogonal control on other signaling
system leading to a cord
physiological
response so let's look now how redoxy
regulation can lead to micro circuit
impairment impacting on palab me
internal runes let's me begin to show
you this
Caron which show actually the micro
which is composed of a pyramidal cell
sending a collaterals to the basket
cells inhibitory neurons containing pvab
a calcium binding protein which can in
turn inhibit the pyramids and the
succession of excitation inhibition lead
to oscillation at high frequency at the
gamma frequency and these buet cell are
unique in this fast fting properties and
the
microcircuit allow PV to time and
synchronize neuronal veox activity in
gamma
frequency and has been shown by many
many labs to be very critical for
cognitive
functions so qus of many Labs especially
that of Francine Benz David Lise show
that pvi as well as the nmda receptors
are impaired in schizophrenia leading to
a disrupted information processing and
integration mediate by gamma oscillation
in Neal nworth then this can
contributing to the symptoms and
cognitive deficits known in
schizophrenia moreover pvi are
particularly vulnerable to Redux
imbalance as the fast piking activity
implies enhanced oxidative metabolism
generating more Rose and thus may need
High antioxidant protection we now ask
the question could oxidative stress pay
a role in pvi
Alteration and or just like in our case
Aion deficit so to investigate this
question we you you use a genetic animal
model of plut deficit in which the T
synthetizing enzyme of plut the plut
lias the modulatory subunits so the gclm
are knock down
and this mice has a quite uniform cratan
deficit across different brain regions
and throughout
life and using a marker for oxidative
stress the eight oo the oxanine which is
a product of DNA oxidation we first
observe the presence of oxidative stress
in the vental hippocampus here shown is
the C3 regions in adult gclm knockout
which is not in present in the white
type and by contrast there was no sign
of oxidative stress in the dorsal
hippocampus and in parallel Yan kab can
show that the pvi imuno reactivity in
the ventral
hippocampus is also impaired so is is is
decrease and particularly strong
decrease in the ca3 and then gers where
oxidative stress you can see here are
the most prominent and you will know
more about the role of these two regions
with the webinar presentation of
Professor Carol
Taminga and this impairment on PBI is
not present in the dorsal hippocampus
and consistent with that morphological
uh
alteration um no so we have looked also
uh like as since Bine inter neurons are
necessary for the neural synchronization
in the gamma frequency range Pascal St
has look for the ability of Kate to
induce local gamma oscillation in
hippocampus slides and you can see here
that the gamma oscillation is quite
decreased in the ventral hippocampus
while it not affected at all in the
dorsal hippocampus of knockout mice and
consistent with the pvi uh impairment
and neuros synchronization deficit in
vent campus all related Behavior Uh to
vental hyppocampus such as impair
emotion stress social behavior and
sensor gating are altered in outm while
the behavior related to Dorsal
hippocampus remains
unaffected so now we ask the question is
there some how is the gene environment
interaction between reduxx and the
environment so as mentioned earlier a
severe environmental insults could lead
to additional oxidative stress so
together with Pascal and Jan we have
asked the question does an additional
stress affect pvi in the anterior
singulate of knock Al mise and is there
any specific period during the
development when additional stress is
particularly
to PBI
interes so here you can appreciate that
early life stress increase oxidative
stress and decrease pvi in Al simulate
of knockout gclm
knockout and we know that environmental
insults would induce an increase of
dopamine release in the prefontal cortex
and dopamine itself may also gener
generate Rose and so H22 of prown
through its metabolism th to mimic
environmental stress we treated our mice
with a dopamine upake inhibitor the
TBR uh which then induce an excess of
extracellular dopamine in region so with
dopamin terminal such as the prefontal
CeX and we treat that during
juvenile during per puberty 30 to 40 or
during
adulthood and then assess for oxidative
stress and you can appreciate here that
is after the chveni periportal or adult
stress there are a strong increase of O
uh oxidative stress
mark which is present in The Knockout
but not in the White Tide indicating
that in the White Tide without the
genetic risk the upregulation of
antioxidant system is quite
efficient now concerning pvi imuno
reactivity you can appreciate here that
the childhood and and the treni and the
peripubertal stress decrease pvi while
the adult stress has no effect so effect
at
all so if I can summarize here for you
looking for pvi counts you can see here
it is the white type and in the knock
knockout uh gclm knockout M there is
only a decrease of pvi in the adulthood
significant but now if we can add
additional stress of the chenile you can
see a strong decrease of pvi in knockout
not in white eye the same when the
stress is applied at per puberty but the
adult stress has no effect at all on on
the KN out mice and now what is more
interesting is that the juiz stress
which lead to a decrease of
pvi the the the effect proceeds into
adulthood here as you can see here in
The Knockout
nice and so the question come could pvi
impairment be reversed or prevented by
antioxidant
treatment so we use an atin cin which is
a safe antidote for ctin
andan deficiency known as a precursor of
putat and itself has also an antioxidant
effect so we apply so we treat since
pregnancy on kn
and you can see here KN can totally
reverse the decrease of
pvi uh up uh in knockout M after the
peral
stress so if I can summarize in the
mouse aatan deficit so coming from a
gene R Gene combined with the stress
environmental during development leads
to Lasting impairment of pabin neurons
of their per neuron net I don't have
time to show you but we have seen that
also and the neuronal synchronization in
the medial prefontal CeX in VI during
infancy and Adolescence these effects of
stress are delous and long lasting while
they are not at told if occurring in
adulthood and they can be completely
reversed by the antioxidant n we can
then uh uh speculate now translation to
patient that that individual who carry a
genetic
vulnerability has a risk to develop
psychosis if they are exposed to
environmental insults during brain
development those insults can be
infectious traumatic or psychosocial and
has been shown that at the origin of
oxidative stress they could induce
empowerment of pvi of my Lim as you will
see after and of neural synchronization
and cognitive function so it is also
tempting for us to speculate
that the timing of the environmental
insults impacting on at individuals may
determine which micro circuit or macro
circuit could be structurally or
functionally affected so and depending
on the neuro neural stage at the time
when the gene environmental interaction
is taking place different circuitry so
such as sensory motor or language or
cognition could be affected and
different could then um could then lead
to a an a kind of heterogenous clinical
phenotype and this hypothesis is
currently being test in our lab so can
reduxx dis regulation also impact micro
circuits so now in
impacting fiber tracks connecting
various brain
regions so wide matter abnormalities as
assesses by DTI are found both in
chronic and early stage of schizophrenia
and there are converging evidence also
that mine and oligo bendrite alteration
are are present in
schizophrenia and we have made an
intriguing obser observation so than to
multimodal Imaging using mrss so
magnetic resonance spectroscopy
assessing plat in the medial prefontal
cortex and diffusion Spectrum Imaging
assessing white metal Integrity along
the singul bundle uh we see that is a
correlation both in control and patient
ofion with uh white metal Integrity as
assesses by fractional anot y here along
the cingulum suggesting that brain
cion levels play a critical role in
white matter
Integrity so it is also known by gu of
mar Noble's L that the Redux state is a
central modulator of the balance between
proliferation and differentiation of
olroy precursor cell which are making
the and actually he he can show that the
reduced stat lead to more proliferation
while oxidizing status lead more to
differentiation and this is what Alim
Mona has tested in vitro in oligo Dental
s uh precursor cell culture and um the
uh in gclc shrna Aion deficit lead to
decrease proliferation totally reversed
by KN as early differentiation and also
impair mine uh maturation as you can see
here and this is consistent also we can
see in invo where cratan deficit inat in
chm knockout M lead to impairment of
mine here with uh miline basic protein
markers so inv Vivo in anti singulate at
peripuberty at uh various uh layers of
the cortex
so what could be the underlying
mechanism we just ask the question
whether put aan deficit conditions the
switch of olgod denty perel from
proliferation to differentiation could
be mediated by the F kyes Pathways
indeed f is which is a non-receptor
tyrosin chinise is regulated by Redux
sensitive
proteins and oxidative Str condition
lead to upregulation of f uh
upregulation of ccbl decrease of pdgfr
and the switch from proliferation to
early differentiation and this is that
Alim can Aline can show both in invivo
in vitro in olroy percursor this
disregulation of the F kise here
activity and also in invivo in GCM
knockout with the the uh F mRNA
expression and the question is can these
results can be translated and validated
in patient and very
interestingly together with Margo for
Alim can show that the same impairment
that's mean here the up regulation of of
f fin activity can be seen in patients
actually it is early psychosis patient
in their fibroblast specifically the
highrisk cath the highrisk genotype cion
patient so this regulation of f in
patient can actually be predicted by our
oxidative stress
models so what are the fiber tracts that
could be affected uh in by oxidative
stress so Alberto
Coba uh uh with ro K and J D has
developed a cutting age 14 Tesla
diffusion tension Imaging in GCM
knockout M assessing the wide matter
Integrity in the whole brain in
Vivo and you can appreciate here the
reduced fractional
anisotropy in the foric sria as well and
in the anterior Commission in cclm
knockout
M and not in the white so cont to the
White type and uh here with the
longitudinal study during development so
uh uh Alberto can find that there is a
reduced fractional
anisotropy already present at per
puberty and existing all along until
adulthood now what is the functional
Insight of fractional anisotropy
alteration so the fa and interestingly
uh Pascal CH uh can show that this is
correlated very well with reduced
conduction velocity in the same fibers
in the foric as measured by
electrophysiology so the phic fmria is
the main output of the hippocampus and
very critical for cognitive function and
in this alteration is involved in memory
deficit we then ask the question can the
white matter Integrity alteration of the
phonics in our mind in our model can
predict the same anomalies in patient
and this is exactly what Philip bman and
Alexandra kria has looked for in early
psychosis patient that is a significant
decrease of fractional anisotropy in the
form as well as a decrease of the
hippocampal
volume and interestingly in the patient
uh we can find a correlation between
hipocampal volume and Fa in the phic
that reduce white metal Integrity in the
phonic is associated with smaller
hipocampal volume and this is present in
the patient but not in the
control so my assumer Riz in the micro
circuit mine anomalies are found in both
patients and models of oxidative stress
the F K
disregulation is an underlying mechanism
of Ming impairment both for M and
patient they could be as potential early
markers we have identified also
impairments of the fiber tract the for
important for memory in the early phase
of cyclosis correlated hpoc comple
volume and again here we can speculate
that this process may also affect many
other Pathways now let's switch here and
go to the
bramate uh nmda receptors and
inflammation so uh let's first look at
nmba receptor hypofunction and
interaction with Redux dis regulation
just a
reminder that nmba receptor hypofunction
is play a key role in schizophrenia
pathophysiology as the antagonist such
as ketamine cycline induce positive
negative and cognitive symptoms in
control subject exacerbates that in uh
patients and also in psychosis and
hallucination has been found in patient
with
autoimmune uh nmda receptors analitis
and last but not least the deficit known
in schizophrenia in auditory evoke
mishmash negativity are associated with
impair and MBA receptor
function so I want now to quote very
interesting wonderful work of chill
Haring gam who has shown that activation
of synaptic but not extra synaptic NDA
receptors boost the in intrinsic
antioxidant system so namely the Tor
redoxin and peroxy toxine Pathways but
very recently now in press in nature
communication uh CH lab can show also
that nmba reactivity play a key role in
regulating the capacity of cat system
through the direct transcriptional
control of of of cat promoting is
synthesis Recycling and
utilization and this Le that an MBA
receptor hyper activity during
development does may lead to deleterious
loss of this
control and moreover a timee work of
stillw lion has shown that under nmda
receptors there are rux sensitive
s uh in which so on specifically on nr1
and one
nr2a in which either uh reducing agent
such as theot tror DT or or plut can
potentiate the nmda
activity so and also nmda hyper function
Indus either by ketamine and shown by
MAA V Barons or in conditional knockout
of
nr1 uh as shown by naaga leads to pvi
impairment through oxidative stress as
you can see here um uh Mara has shown
that nmda receptor had uh with ketamine
lead to induction of cytokines y six
induction of NPH oxidase which the main
generator of rose and and super oxide
and leading to to pvi impairment so we
speculate that uh cahan deficit either
can act directly or can act through nmba
receptor hyper function leading to evi
impairment and this is what Pascal has
looked for he can show that toon deficit
leads to nmda receptor hyper function
and long-term potentiation empowerment
in hipocampal
slid so
now so you can see that Redux
disregulation and nmda receptor hyper
function can interact in Synergy
creating a vicious cycle that is
particularly the leruse for pvi now how
about inflammation and Redux
disregulation there is now emerging
evidence for an increase inflammation in
the brain CSF and blood of schizophrenia
patient and as you have already seen
there is an increase of oxidative stress
in our knockout and as you can see here
in anterior singulate at the per puberty
so P40
uh as show by Daniela danela has show
now also observe in the same region and
same age an increase of microban
activation and this is quite specific as
in region with no oxidative stress such
as somat somat sensory cotic that is no
sign of microbial activation and more
interestingly uh the oxidative stress
induced microbial activation is is more
prominent at per puberty than at adult
stage suggesting that neuroinflammation
may be early May conserve as early uh
markers now it is known also that there
is a tight and
reciprical interaction between redoxy
regulation and
neuroinflammation so Rose can induce
inflammatory Pathways while micral
activation indu R uh production
oxidative stress produce H which is a
Lian of Rage which can then induce an
inflammatory uh response via an F cap
and vice versa neuroinflammation can
increase s beta to Li of Rage which can
induce rast VI production of NPH oxidase
so making rage the receptor for advanc
citation and product uh a potential link
between the two processes and this is
what uh danela has tried to to test and
um here uh ad try to see if oxidative
stress can induce rage sh shedding uh as
an under potential underlying mechanism
so you can see here rage can be shed or
CLE
into extra cellular a soluble form and a
intranuclear r which can then be
translated to nucleus and induce all the
inflammatory response and uh you can see
here that in gclm knockout mice that is
an increase of R shedding as well as an
increase of s00 beta so the Lian of
Rage so here again that is a tight
interaction between inflammation and
ruis regulation that could lead to a
deleterious positive Fe work
effect now in so to summarize Redux
immune and glutamic system can form a
triade in which each of its element can
influence each other and this regulation
of one system would in turn impact on
the other
system we now ask the question good
models independent of redu this
manipulation also lead to oxidative
stress and in collaboration with tsho
Odon we then studied uh the
developmental rat model of schizophrenia
the So-Cal neetal ventral hippocampal
lesion the
nvhl in which a lesion of the Ventra
hippocampus has been done at p7 and all
the schizophrenia phenotype related fot
type emerge during adolescence and we
can ask the question could oxidative
stress be one of the mechanism
underlying this delay emergence of
schizophrenia phenotype and can an
antioxidant as a knock can reverse
it and uh you can see here uh Yan Kabal
can see that is a strong so both at
chveni and Adolescence of P 61 and
increase of oxidative stress mark But in
parallel
pabin uh cells are only decreased in
adolescence but not significant in
chveni and more interestingly if we give
KN before the legion we can prevent all
these
alteration so besides this morphological
alteration uh uh patrio can show that n
can reverse uh
electrophysiological physiological
response such as the D2 modulation loss
of synaptic respon in medal prefrontal
cortex of pyramidal cells as well as the
mishmash negative
which is quite related to nmda receptor
hyper function and more importantly that
KN can also prevented the sensor gating
as assessed here by the pr prepulse
inhibition and now we ask the question
how about we have now treat KN before
the legion how about now if we treat the
animals only during
adolescence and quite
interestingly n can also reverse the
alteration in PPI even if the treatment
is given only during
adolescence
so the oxidative stress and pvi
impairment is induced by Intervention
which are independent of Redux
manipulation suggesting that it is one
of the core pathophysiological mechanism
and oxidative stress may be one
mechanism under underlying the delay
emergence of anomalies driven by
developmental alteration and preventing
oxidative stress with KN or excellent
and another antioxidant can Rescue all
the morphological physiological and
behavioral schizophrenia kot that's
Paving the way to prophylactic treatment
now I just want to end so to to to to to
um to to to to end with a collaboration
so the the very recent uh results done
in collaboration with Tako Hench you may
know the land work Landmark work of Taco
Hench on the critical periods of
plasticity the his SL can show that the
opening and and closure of um critical
periods are are uh mainly so depend on
CVI maturation and also on the per
neuronal neck this is the extracellular
Matrix with en wrap uh PV and uh and and
which protect also PV from oxidative
stress and also M information are are
are critically involved in these two
processes and this is the the two
processes which are precisely the factor
impact in reduxx dis regulation
condition so in conditional knockout of
uh cion synthetizing
enzyme uh specifically on
pvi uh morishita and Yan kabuna can show
that that is an increase of oxidative
stress and decrease of pvi and
pnn and more
interestingly uh uh they can show that
in adult monocular depre
in The Knockout mice the conditional
knockout mice the ocular dominance
distribution continue to be Shi uh away
from the deprise eyes and the same
result you can see here in the
contralateral bias index the CBI in The
Knockout mice there are still a shift of
ocular dominance toxicity beyond the
peak of the natural critical
period so uh in Redux disregulated
condition the na cortex remain plastic
even beyond the peak of the natural
critical period so suggesting that Redux
regulation May balance the plasticity
and stability of cortical networks and
the M time developmental trajectory of
plasticity uh May underline uh at least
in part in the pathophysiology of
schizophrenia
so now as told told you in the beginning
it is so important for us to come back
to the patient and this is what we have
done in the proof of concept clinical
trial together with M Michael be to give
KN uh for to uh in the double blind
randomized Placebo control trial 240
patient and you can see here that KN
given in addition to anti psychotics can
improve the negative symptoms so
symptoms which are not well treated by
the anti psychotics and also you can
appreciate here already the effect can
be already seen after two months here is
the severity of the symptoms with knock
and besides that Knack can also improve
the nmj receptor dependent bmar
negativity as well as the local
synchronization so the retion of Redux
this regulation with a safe precursor
for Kion open New Perspective for
treatment and prevention and this is
what we try to now test with uh a
randomized double blind clinical trial
now in first episode patient together
with Philip Kus and Larry
Simon so for the perspective we uh can
say that maybe the intervention if there
are some sorry intervention uh should
start early possibly at the time where
there are the environmental insults and
maybe with some efficient but
benign uh um such uh treatment such as
Redux modulator impacting on this triade
hat that I had discussed with you uh
before so in conclusion ruis regulation
in full interaction with nmj receptor
camate dysfunction and
neuroinflammation is a core mechanism
for both micro and micro alteration in
schizophrenia that in micit oxidative
stress resulting from conjuctions of R
Gene and environmental insults during
development affect selectively pvi and
perineuronal net in a region and time
specific manner and early insults are
more delerious than adults on and lead
to impairment lasting in adulthood they
may sh light on potential mechanism
underlying longlasting consequences of
early environmental insults in the
context of unmat environmental risk
factors for
schizophrenia in terms of micro circuits
redu this regulation can impair
proliferation of olgod denty percursor
to the fin kyes pathway leading to
minding deficits in models and
predicting fin K disregulation and
disconnectivity in patient so together
micro and macro circuit deficit lead to
an imbalance of excitation inhibition
and to an impair local and distant
neuronal synony th underlying cognitive
behavioral anomalies in analogy to
patients and type and many of these
empowerment can be prevented by timely
Administration of antil C in does
opening New Perspective for stage
specific treatment and for prevention in
patient so I would like to thanks a
knowledge and all my students and post
do I'm so fortunate to have so talented
and motivated students and post and also
would like to thanks uh Philip Kus the
head of the service of Psychiatry with
whom I am working now from head in hand
to to build this program and also
Michelle queno which has been a constant
support and with whom I has also start
this program I also thanks all my
collaborators in loan as well as psho o
donel and taka pen and also thanks to
all the financing agencies especially uh
the siny the nccr siny and all the uh
private Foundation
the foundation a which are instrumental
to help us to do this uh project thank
you for your
attention thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I'd like
to remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can on our first
question is would you recommend that
higher levels of glutathione cyano
hydroxy
buttin and sinee sulfur containing foods
normal foods are incorporated into
inpatient mental health children's Wards
and recommended to those in need in the
community
so yes uh this is quite an interesting
question the main problem with
cione is that it doesn't cross well the
blood rain barrier so this is why knock
has been used but Knack has also some
limit limiting um factor is is Closs the
blood B barrier but also not very well
so we have to find much better Redux
modulators so I cannot answer right now
but uh this is a quite interesting
yeah
next next next question is extra
synaptic
means kill
Harding what CH Hingham has shown in
this his uh uh I think Nature
Neuroscience paper and now also in the
commun nature communication with cion he
has indu uh intas Coptic so he can
stimulate the the the the N receptors in
the syapse but not the extra synoptic I
think is through treatment with for
aminopurine you may have a look on on
this paper so intra in intra sinapic
versus extra synaptic
okay
so next question is what are the hypo
function hypo functions of nmda is there
any compensatory mechanism for nmda
hypofunction EG mgl
RS
any the question is is there any
compensatory mechanism for nmda receptor
hyper function for example from the uh
metabotropic toic
receptors uh yes maybe uh that there has
been a work of other groups showing that
hyper function of nmj receptors may lead
to increase of extra so so camate levels
and then acting on metabotropic
receptors namely the uh the two free uh
class can decrease the release of
glutamate yes there are some some uh
work on on this part uh going on
yeah can schizophrenia be diagnosed in
childhood this is quite a challenging
until now uh so normally it's quite
difficult to be dagos in childhood but
there are uh uh um a cohort which is now
you may heard about that Chi tro port
and N Go has at the N are following
since long time which is childhood onset
of schizophrenia and that has been
detected in children uh very early so
the same sign that we see in adult so
schizophrenia does does lithium provide
antioxidant benefits in this patient
group quite interesting question so as
far as I know uh there is there are some
work in in this part but there is not
yet
convincing convincing evidence for that
so I I cannot I I I cannot say exactly
about
that okay what tests for gsh function
should be done and when to help prevent
schizophrenia there's a couple questions
here I'll throw them all at you let me
know if you if you need them uh
separately so anyway what tests for gsh
function should be done and when to help
prevent schizophrenia what doses have
been used in humans what it helped to
administer NAC when given immunization
with Mercury based
preservatives it's
quite uh now let me answer
first
okay let me answer first what test for
cion function should be done so uh now
uh as as as as said in in in my talk we
are trying now to see if we can have
some peripheral markers for Caton
deficit but uh we are developing uh so
magnetic resonance spectroscopy to see
Catan deficit in the brain as you can
see here even the highis genotype can
predict already the the low Craton level
but something that uh one may also think
about is uh testing on the
paladine um impairment so we know that
palab mean impairment lead to a decrease
of gamma
synchronization so that can be also that
may assesses with EEG in patient and I
know that many groups are developing and
trying to see that in
patience Okay
so
could you tell me please where you see
any link between autoimmune disorders
such as multiple sclerosis and Redux
State
schizophrenia interesting question again
um as you can see autoimmune so Auto
antibody against nmga receptors has been
associated with psychosis in
hallucination and that can be treated so
the the the symptoms goes away with a
treatment with imuno depression okay now
with Redux disregulation this is a quite
interesting test
Um this can be I I don't know that that
has now to be tested and this is mainly
that we are doing right now in our knout
M trying to see if with not we can
reverse the micropal activation and also
all the the the the r shedding that that
we are we are doing right now but for
autoimmune
disorder it's difficult to know right
now
yeah
have you looked at the new medication
gx13 in respect to nr2a subunit
malfunction in in MD is your opinion it
might might it
help quite interesting what I know that
the glycine it has been now tested by
for example the D Ser which is acting as
a coagonist of nmda receptors so as
shown by uh uh Dan Javid has quite so
improved the negative symptoms but for
the Kine
EX3 on nr2
subunit I don't know if somebody uh but
it's worth to try yes it's worth to try
but I I suggest that it may do that okay
it may have some effect on um reversing
or at least ameliorated the nmda
receptor hyper
function would you recommend adding NAC
supplements to schizophrenic adult drug
regimes so of course now as not is in
the research we cannot uh propose as
really an um you know in as a treatment
but
um uh what we are trying to do now is to
see if KN can improve sub ties of uh of
patient of course not cannot be a
miracle uh treatment but may apply to
well a sub type of patient the one which
has oxidative stress or Redux
disregulation or even nmj receptor
hyperfunction this is what we are trying
to do but as not has rare uh um has side
effects um many so around here in the
loan uh there are many psychiatrist who
has given that to adult to adult patient
and uh some some it is anecdotic but
some has c a quite nice
Improvement but this is what I can do
but you are doing that kind of research
right
now unfortunately we are out of time I
want to thank the audience for their
interesting questions and participation
in today's event I would also like to
thank Professor doe for her informative
presentation today's webcast will be
available for OnDemand viewing for
several months following you'll receive
an email from labroots alerting you when
this webcast will be available for
replay we invite you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event see you
next time
goodbye